The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So we've been trying to
understand critical points.
And this refers to the
experimental observation
that in a number
of systems we can
be changing some parameters,
such as temperature,
and you encounter a transition
to some other type of behavior
at some point.
So the temperature, let's
say, in this behavior
is the control parameter.
And you have to
see, for example,
this will be normal to
superfluid transition.
You have one now [INAUDIBLE]
change temperature and going
through this point.
For other systems,
such as magnets,
you actually have two knobs.
There is also the
magnetic field.
And there, you have
to turn two knobs
in order to end at
this critical point,
also in the case of the liquid
gas system in the pressure
temperature plane, you
have to tune two things
to get this point.
And the interesting thing
was that in the vicinity
of his point, the singular
parts of various thermodynamic
quantities are interestingly
independent of the type
of material.
So if we, for example, establish
a coordinate at t and h
describing deviations
from this critical point,
we have, let's say,
the singular part
of free energy as a
function of t and h
has a form like t to
the 2 minus alpha,
some scaling function
ht to the delta,
and these exponents, alpha
and delta, other things
that are universe.
For example, we
could get from that
by taking two derivatives with
respect to h, the singularity
and the divergence of
the susceptibility.
And we said that the
diverging susceptibility also
immediately tells you that
there is a correlation then
that diverges, and
in particular, we
indicated its divergence
to an exponent u.
WE could for that also
establish a scaling form
on how the correlation
then diverges
on approaching this point
generally in the ht plane.
So this was the general picture.
And building on that, we made
one observation last time,
which is that any point when
you are away from h and t
equals to 0, you have
a correlation length.
And then we concluded that if
you are at t and h equals to 0,
you have a form of
scaling vertices.
And basically what
that means is that when
you are at that point,
you look at your system,
it's a fluctuating system,
and the fluctuations are
such that you can't
associate a scale with them.
The scale has already
gone into the correlation
length that is infinite.
And we said that
therefore, if I were
to look at some kind of
a correlation function,
such as a magnetization
in the case of a magnet,
that the only way that
it became its separation
is as a power of a distance.
And this clearly has
a property that if we
were to rescale x and
y by a certain amount,
this correlation function
nearly gets multiplied
by a factor that is
dependent on this rescale.
And this is after
we do the averaging,
so it's a kind of
statistical self-singularity,
as opposed to some factor such
as Sierpinkski gasket, which
are identically and
deterministically
self-similar in that each
piece, if you blow it up,
looks like the entire thing.
So what we have in our system
is that if we have, let's say,
a box which could be
containing our liquid gas
system at its critical
point, or maybe a magnet
at its critical point, will
have a statistical field,
this m of x.
And it will fluctuate
across the system.
So maybe this would be a picture
of the density fluctuation.
What I can do is to take a scan
along some particular axis--
let's call it x-- and plot
what the fluctuations are
of this magnetization.
Let's say m of x.
Now the average
will be 0, but it
will have fluctuations
around the average.
And so maybe it
will look something
like this-- kind of like
a picture of a mountain,
for example.
Now one thing that
we should remember
is that this object would
be piece of iron or nickle,
and clearly I don't
really mean that this
is what is going on at
the scale of a single atom
or molecule of my substance.
I had to do some kind
of averaging in order
to get the statistical field
that I'm presenting here.
So let's keep in
mind that there is,
in fact, some implicit
analog of lattice size
or some implicit
shortest distance,
shortest wavelength that I
allow for my frustrations.
Now I can sort of make this
idea of scale invariance
of a set of pictures, such
as this one, more precise,
as follows, by going
through a procedure
that I will call renormalization
that has the following three
steps.
So the first step, what I will
do is to coarse-grain further.
And by this, I mean averaging
m of x over a scale ta.
So previously, I had done my
averaging of whatever means,
et cetera.
We're giving contribution
to the overall magnetization
over some number,
let's 100 by 100 by 100
spins and a was my
scaling distance.
Why should I choose 100?
Why not choose 200, some factor
of what I had originally?
So coarse-graining means
increasing this minimum length
scale from a to ba.
And then I define a
coarse-grained version
of my field.
So previously, I had m of x.
Now I have m tilda of x, which
is obtained by averaging,
let's say, over volume around
the point x that I had before.
And this volume is a box
of dimension ba to the d.
And then I basically
average over that.
I guess let's call it
original distance a equals 1,
so I don't really have to bother
by the dimensionality of y,
et cetera.
OK?
So if I were to apply
that to the picture
that I have up
there, what do I get?
I will get an m tilda
as a function of x.
And essentially,
let's say if I were
to choose a factor
of b that was like 2,
I would take the average
of the fluctuations
that they have over 2 of
those of those intervals.
And so the picture
that I would get it
would be kind of a
smoothened out version
of what I have
before over there.
I will still have
some fluctuations,
but kind of ironed out.
And basically,
essentially, it means
that if you were to imagine
having taken a photograph,
previously you had the
pixel size that was 1.
Now your pixel size is larger.
It is factor of b.
So it's this kind of
detuning and averaging
of the fluctuations
that has gone.
And so you have here now b.
Now if I were to give you
a photograph like that
and a photograph
like this, you would
say that they are not identical.
One of them is clearly much
grainier than the other.
So I say, OK, I can restore
some amount of similarity
between them by
doing a rescaling.
So I call a new variable x prime
to be my old variable x divided
by a factor of b.
So when I do that
to this picture,
I will get m tilda as
a function of x prime.
x prime can go in further
less, because all I do
is I take this and squeeze
it by a factor of b.
So I will get a
picture that maybe
looks something like this.
Now if I were to look at this
picture and this picture,
you would also see a difference.
That is, there is a contrast.
So here, there would be,
let's say, black and white.
And as you scan the
picture, you sort of see
some variation of
black and white.
If you look at this, you say
the contrast is just too big.
You have big fluctuations
as you go across
compared to what
I had over there.
So there's another step, which
is called renormalize, which
is that you define
m prime to be m
by a change of
contrast factor zeta.
So you take a knob that
corresponds to contrast
and you reduce it
until you see pictures
that kind of statistically look
like what you started with.
So in order to sort of generate
pictures that are self-similar,
you have this one knob.
Basically, scaling variance
means the change of size.
But there is associated
with change of size
a change of contrast
for whatever variable
you are looking at.
It turns out that that
change of contrast
would eventually map to
one of these exponents
that we have over there.
Yes.
STUDENT: Are you
using m or n tilda?
PROFESSOR: m tilda, thank you.
So I guess the green
is m tilda of x prime,
and the pink is m
prime of x prime.
So what I have done
mathematically is as follows.
I have defined an
m prime of x prime,
which is 1 over zeta,
this contrast factor
b to the d because of the
averaging over a volume
that involved b to the d pixels
of the original field centered
at a location that
was bx prime plus y.
So in principle, I
can go and generate
lots and lots of configurations
of my magnetization,
or lots and lots of pictures
of a system at the liquid gas
critical point, or
magnetic systems
at their critical point.
I can generate lots and
lots of these pictures
and construct this
transformation.
And associated with
this transformation
is a change of
probability, because there
was some probability--
let's call it P old,
that was describing my
original configurations m of x.
Let's forget the vector
notation for the time being.
Then there will be, after this
transformation, probability
that describes these
configurations m
prime of x prime.
Now you know that
averaging is not something
that you can reverse.
So this transformation
going from here and here,
I cannot go back.
There are many
configurations over here
that would correspond
to the same average,
like up, down or down,
up would give you
the same average, right?
So a number of
possibilities here
have to be summed up to
generate for you this object.
Now the statement of
self-similarity presumably
is that this weight is
the same as this weight.
You can't tell apart that
you generated configurations
before or after that scaling.
So this is same
at critical point.
I've not constructed
either weight,
so it really doesn't
amount to much.
But Kadanoff
introduced this concept
of doing this and thinking of
it as a kind of group operation
called renormalization
group that I
describe a little bit better
and evolve the description as we
go along.
So if I look at my
original system,
I said that
self-similarity occurs,
let's say, exactly at this
point that corresponds to t
and h equals to 0.
Now presumably, I
can, in some sense,
force these things, if I were
to take its log, for example.
I can construct some
kind of a weight that
is associated with
m, and this would
be a new weight that is
associated with m prime.
Presumably, right at
the critical point,
these two would be
the same weight,
and it would be the
same Hamiltonian.
What happens, if I
do this procedure,
to a system that is initially
away from the critical point?
So my initial system is
characterized by deviations t
and h from this scale
in variant ways, which
means that over here I
have a correlation length.
Now I go through all of
these transformations.
I can do those
transformations also
for a point that is not
at the critical point.
But at the end of
the day, I certainly
will not get back
my original weight,
because I look at the picture
after this transformation.
Before the transformation, I
had a long correlation length,
let's say a mile.
When I do this transformation,
that correlation length
is reduced by a factor of b.
So the new system has deviated
more from the critical point.
Because the further you go
away from the critical point,
you have a larger
correlation length.
So the idea is that right
at the critical point,
the two weights are the same.
Deviation from
the critical point
is described by these
two parameters, t and h.
And if you do the
renormalization procedure
on a Hamiltonian
that deviates, you
will get a Hamiltonian
that more deviates, still
describable by parameters
t and h that have changed.
So again, this says
that c was, in fact,
b times c of t
prime and h prime,
and t prime and h
prime are further away.
Now the next thing that Kadanoff
said was, OK, therefore there
is a transformation
that tells me
after I do a rescaling
by a factor of b how
the new t and the new h depend
on the old t and the old h.
So there is a mapping
in this space.
So a point that was
here will go over there.
Maybe a point that is
here will map over there.
A point that is here
will map over here.
So there is a mapping
that tells you
how th get transformed
under this procedure.
Actually the reason this is
called a renormalization group,
groups we are really
thinking usually
in terms of operations
that are invertible.
This transformation
is not invertible.
But this is a mapping.
So potentially this
mapping is invertible.
You can say that if this
point came from this point
under inversion, it will go
back to the original point,
and so forth.
The next part of the argument
is what did we do over here?
We got rid of some short
wavelength fluctuations.
Now one of the things that I
said right at the beginning
was that as long as you are
getting rid of short scale
fluctuations, you are summing
over a cube that his 100
square, 200 cube.
It doesn't matter,
100 cube, 200 cube--
you are doing some
analytical function.
So the transformation
that relates these
to these, the old to new,
should be analytical,
and hence you should be able to
write a Taylor series for it.
So let's try to make a
Taylor series for this.
Taylor series start
with a constant.
But we know that the constant
has to be 0 in both cases
because the starting
point was the point that
was scale invariant and
was mapping onto itself.
So the first thing that I can
write down are linear terms.
So there could be a term
that is proportional to t.
There could be a term
that is proportional to h.
There could be a term here
There could be a term
that is proportional--
well, let's call this t.
Let's call this h.
And then there
will be terms that
will be order of t
squared and higher.
So I just did an
analytical expansion,
justified by this summing over
just finite degrees of freedom
at short scale.
Now if I have a structure,
such as the one that I
have over there, I
also know some things
on the basis of symmetry.
Like if I'm on the line that
corresponds to h equals to 0,
there is no difference
between up and down.
Under rescaling, I still
don't know the difference
between up and down.
So I should not generate
an h if h was originally 0
just because t deviated from 0.
So by symmetry, that
has to be absent.
And similarly, by
symmetry, there
is no difference between
h positive and h negative.
As far as t is concerned, h and
minus h should behave the same.
So this series should start at
order of h squared and not h,
so that term should be absent.
So at this level, we have a nice
separation into t prime is at
and h Prime.
Is dh.
Now we know
something more, which
is that the procedure
that we are doing
has some kind of a group
character, in that if I,
let's say, originally
transform by some factor b1,
change by a factor of 2,
then change by a factor of 3,
the answer is equivalent to
changing by a factor of 2
times 3, or 3 times 2.
Doesn't matter in
which order I do them.
So also, I would get,
if I were to do b1 first
and b2 later, it would
be the same thing.
So what does that imply?
That if I do two of
these transformation,
I find that my new t is obtained
in one case by the product,
in the other case by the
product of the two a's.
So that's, again, some
kind of a group character.
And furthermore, if I don't
change the length scale,
everything should
stay where it is.
So you glance at
those, and you find
that there is only
one possibility,
that a as a function of b
should be b to some power.
So you know therefore
that at the lowest
order under rescaling
by a factor of b,
t prime should be b
to some y-- I called
it yt-- times t
plus higher orders,
while h prime is b to some other
power of yh times h plus higher
orders.
And you say, OK, fine.
What's this good for?
Well, let's take a look
at what we did over there.
We said that I take some bunch
of initial configurations,
sum their weights
to get the weight
of the new configuration.
What happens if I sum over
all initial configurations?
Well, if I sum over all
initial configuration,
I will get the
partition function.
Now essentially,
all the original
configurations I
regrouped and put
into these coarse-grained
configurations that
are weighted this way.
So there could be
an overall constant
that emerges from this.
But this really implies that
the singular part of log z,
and presumably this
depends on how far
away I am from the
critical point,
is the same as log z that
singular after I do this t
prime and h prime.
Now there is one other
issue, which is extensivity.
Up to signs, factors
of beta, et cetera,
this is b times an
intensive free energy,
which is a function of t and h.
So this is the same as v prime,
because the volume shrunk.
I took all of my scales and
shrunk it by a factor of v,
v prime, f of t
prime and h prime.
So now let's go this way.
Note that v prime is
the original v divided
by b to the d scaling factor.
So you do the
divisions here, and you
find that f as a
function of t and h
is the ratio of v prime to
v, which is b to the minus d,
f as a function of
t prime and h prime.
But t prime we said to lowest
order is b to the yt t.
h prime is b to the yh h.
This is actually the
more correct form
of writing a
homogeneous function.
So previously in
last lecture, we
assumed that the free energy
had a homogeneous form.
Now subject to these
conditions and assumptions
of renormalization
group, we have
concluded that it should
have that homogeneous form.
Now you say this
homogeneous form does not
look like the
homogeneous forms that I
had written for you before.
I say, OK.
Presumably this is true
for any factor of b
that I want to choose.
Let me choose a b, a rescaling
factor such that v to the yt t
is of the order of 1.
Could be 1, could be pi.
I don't care.
Which means that
I chose a factor
of b that will scale with t
as t to the minus 1 over yt.
I put this b-- this expression
is true for all choices of b.
If I chose that particular
value, what I get
is t to the d over
yt, some function.
First argument has now
become 1 or some constant.
Really it only depends
on the second argument
in the combination h and t
to the power of yh over yt.
So you can see that
this is, in fact,
the same as the first
line that I have above.
And I have identified
that 2 minus alpha
would be related to
this factor of yt, which
is how you would scale
under renormalization,
the parameters t and h.
And the gap exponent is related
to the ratio of yh over yt.
Similarly, we had that
the correlation length--
I have a line there.
Psi of t and h is b psi
of t prime and h prime.
So I have that psi as
a function of t and h
is b times psi as a function of
b to the yt t, b to the yh h.
So that's also correct.
I can again choose this value
of v, substitute it over there.
What do I get?
I get that psi as a
function of t and h
would be t to the
minus 1 over yt,
some scaling function-- let's
call it g psi-- of, again, h
to the power of yh over yt.
So I have got an answer
that nu should be 1 over yt.
I can get the scaling form
for the correlation length.
I identify the divergence
of correlation length
with inverse of this.
And by the way, I get, if I
substitute nu as 1 over yt
here, the Josephson hyperscale
in relation to minus alpha
equals to b.
I can go further if I want.
I can calculate magnetization
as a function of t and h,
would correspond to
basically the behaviors
that we identify with exponents
beta or delta as d log z.
Yeah, let's say f by dh.
If I take a
derivative over there,
you can immediately
see that what
that gives me is b to the
power of yh minus d, and then
some scaling function which is
the derivative of this scaling
function b the yt
t, b to the yh h.
And again, if I
make this choice,
then this goes over to t to the
power of d minus yh over yt,
and then some scaling
function of h t to the delta.
So I can continue with my table.
And for example,
I will have beta
to be d minus yh divided by yt.
I can go and calculate
delta, et cetera.
Actually I was a
little bit careless
with this factor
zeta, which presumably
is implicit in all of these
transformations that I have.
And I have to do special
things to figure out
what zeta is so that I will
get self-similarity right
at the critical point.
But we can see that
already we have
the analog of a rescaling for m.
And so it is easy to sort of
look at those two equations
and identify that my zeta
should be precisely this one.
So the zeta is not
independent of the relevance
of the magnetic field.
And if you think about it, the
field and the magnetization
are conjugate variables in the
sense that in the weight here,
I will have a term that is like
hm-- integrated, of course.
And so hm integrated,
you can see
that up to a factor of b
to the d from integration,
the dimensionality that I assign
to h and the dimensionality
that I assign to m
should be related.
And not only for
the magnetization,
but for any pair of variables
that are so conjugate--
there's some f, and
there's some x--
there will be a corresponding
relation between what
would happen to this x at the
critical point and this factor
f when I deviate from
the critical point.
So all of this is
kind of nice, but it's
a little bit hand waving.
I essentially traded one set of
assumptions about homogeneity
and scaling of free
energy correlation length
to some other set of assumptions
about two parameters moving
away from a scale
invariant critical point.
I didn't calculate anything
about what the scale invariant
probability is.
I didn't show that, indeed,
two parameters are sufficient,
that this kind of scaling
takes place, et cetera.
So we need to be
much more precise
if we want to do, ultimately,
calculations that give us
what these numbers
yt and yh are.
So let's try to put
this hand waving
on a little bit
more firm setting.
So let's see how
we should proceed.
We start with some experimental
system, critical point.
So I tell you that somebody in
the experiment, the liquid gas
system, they saw a diverging
correlation length,
critical opalescence, et cetera.
So then I associate
with that some kind
of a statistical field.
And let's kind of
stick with the notation
that we have for the magnet.
Let's call it m of x.
And in general, this
would be the part
where one needs to put
in a lot of thinking.
That is, the experimentalist
comes and tells you
that I see a system that
undergoes a phase transition.
There are some
response functions
that are divergent, et cetera.
You have to put in some
thinking to think about what
the appropriate
order parameter is.
And based on that order
parameter or statistical field,
you construct the most
general weight consistent
with symmetries, with
not only asymmetries
but the kind of assumptions that
we have been putting in play.
So we put in assumptions
about locality, symmetry.
Stability is, of
course, paramount.
But there is a list of things
that you have to think about.
So once you do
that you say, OK, I
associate with my
configurations m of x some set
of probabilities.
Probabilities are
certainly positive.
So I can take its log, call its
minus its log to be some kind
of a weight, beta h, that
governs these m of x's.
If I say that I'm
obeying locality,
then I would write the answer,
for example, like this.
But it doesn't have to be.
I have to write some
particular example.
But you may construct
your example
depending on the
system of interest.
And let's say we are looking
at something like a superfluid,
maybe, that we don't even have
the analog of magnetic field,
and we go and
construct terms that
are symmetric and made
for a two component m.
And I will write a
few of these terms
to emphasize that this is,
in principle, a long list.
There's coefficient
of m to the sixth.
We saw that the gradient
terms could start with this k.
But maybe there's a
higher order gradient,
and there's essentially
and infinity of terms
that you can write down that
are consistent with these
assumptions that you
have made so far.
So you say, OK.
Now I take this, and implicit
in all of these calculations
is, indeed, some kind
of a short scale cutoff.
To construct the
statistical field,
I do apply the three steps of
RG-- renormalization group,
as I described before.
And this will give me
a new configuration
for each of the
old configurations
through the formula that
I gave you over there.
So in principle, this is just
a transformation from one
set of variables to a
new set of variables.
So if I do this
transformation, I
can calculate the weight
of the new configurations,
m prime of x prime.
I can take minus
the log of that.
And again, up to
some constant, it
will be the same
as a probability.
So there could be,
in this procedure,
some set of constants
that are generated
that don't depend on m.
And then there
will be a function
that depends on m
prime of x prime.
Now the statement
is that since I
wrote the most general function
over here, whatever I put here
will have to have exactly
the same form, because I said
put anything that
you can think of that
is consistent with
symmetries over here.
So you put everything there.
What I put here should have
exactly the same functional
form, but with coefficients
that have changed.
So you basically
prime everything,
but you have this whole thing.
Now this may seem like
truly difficult thing.
But we will actually do this.
We will carry out this
transformation explicitly
in particular cases.
And we will show that this
transformation amounts
to constructing a rescaling of
each one of these parameters--
t prime, u prime, v prime, k
prime, l prime, and so forth--
as functions of
the old parameters.
So this is, if you
like, a mapping.
You take some set of
parameters-- t, u, v, k, l,
blah, blah, blah-- and
you construct a mapping,
s prime, which is some
function of the original set
of parameters.
So this is a huge
dimensional space.
Any points that you start
on the transformation
will go to another point.
But the key is that we
wrote the most general form
that we could, so we had
to stay within this space.
So why are you doing this?
Well, I started by saying that
the key to this whole thing
is have to having a handle as
to what this self-similar scale
invariant probability is.
I can't construct
that just by guessing.
But I can do what we
usually do, let's say,
in constructing wave functions
in quantum mechanics that
have some particular symmetry.
Maybe you start with
some wave function that
doesn't have the full
symmetry, and then
you rotate it and
rotate it again,
and you average
over all of them,
and you end up with
some function that
has the right symmetry.
So we start with a
weight that I don't
know whether it has the
property that I want.
And I apply the action
of the group, which
is this scaling
variance, to see what
happens to it under
that transformation.
But the point that
I am interested,
or the behavior that
is where I basically get
the same probability back.
So I'm very interested
at the point where,
under the transformation,
I go back to myself.
And that's called a fixed point.
So S is a shorthand for this
infinite vector of parameters.
I want to find the point s
star in this parameter space.
Actually, let me call
this transformation R
and indicate that I'm
renormalizing by a scale b,
such that, when I
renormalize by a scale
b, my original
set of parameters,
if I am at this fixed point,
I will end up at that point.
So clearly, this
is a system that
has exactly these properties
that I was harping in
at the beginning.
This is the point that
is truly scale invariant.
That's the point that
I want to get at.
So again, once we have
done this transformation
in a specific case, we'll figure
out what this fixed point is.
But for the time being,
let's think a little bit away
from this and deviate
from fixed point.
So I start with
an initial point S
that is, let's write it, S
star plus a little bit away.
Just like in the
picture that I have
here, I started
with a fixed point,
and I said I go
away by an amount
that I had parameterized
by t and h.
Now I have essentially
a whole line
of deviations forming a vector.
I act with Rb on this, and I
note that if delta S goes to 0,
then I should go back to S star.
But if delta S is
small, maybe I can
look at the delta
S prime, which is
a linearized version of
these transformations.
So basically these
transformations
are highly nonlinear just as
the transformation over here,
in principle, would have
been highly nonlinear.
But then I expanded it around
the point t and h equals to 0.
Similarly, I'm assuming
that this delta S is small,
and therefore delta S prime
can be related to delta S
through the action of a matrix
that is a linearized version.
Let's call it here RL of b.
So this is a linearized
transformation,
which means that
it's really a matrix.
In this particular case, in
principle, I started with a 2
by 2 matrix.
The off diagonal
terms were 0, so it
was only the diagonal
terms that mattered.
But in general, it
would be a matrix,
which would be the
square of whatever
the size of the parameter
space is that I am looking at.
Now then you have
a matrix, it's good
always to think in terms of its
eigenvalues and eigendirection.
In this problem that
I had over here,
symmetries had already
diagonalized the matrix.
I didn't have off
diagonal terms.
But I don't know here.
It could be all kinds
of off diagonal terms.
So the properties are
captured by diagonalize, RL,
which means that I find a set
of vectors in this space--
let's call them Oi-- such
that under action of this,
I will get lambda Oi, lambda i.
Of course, the transformation
depends on the rescaling
parameter, so there
should be a b here.
Now of course, you will get
a totally different matrix
for each b.
So is it really hopeless that
for each b I have to look
at a new matrix, new
diagonalization, et cetera?
Well, exactly this thing
that we had over here
now comes into
play, because I know
that if I make a
transformation size b1 followed
by a transformation size b2,
the answer is a transformation
size b1, b2.
And it doesn't matter
in which order I do it.
AUDIENCE: Can't you just mix
notation, because L used to be
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
So in particular, I see
that these linearized
matrices commute with each
other for different values of b.
And again, from your
quantum mechanics,
you probably know that
if matrices commute then
they have the same eigenvectors.
So essentially, I was correct
here in putting no index b
on these eigenvectors,
because it's
independent of eigenvector,
whereas the eigenvalues,
in principle, depend on b.
And how they depend on
b is also determined
by this transformation, that is
lambda i of b1, lambda i of b2
should be the same
thing as lambda b1, b2.
And of course, lambda
i of 1 should be 1.
If you don't change scale,
nothing should change.
And this is exactly the
same set of conditions
as we have over
here, which means
that we know that the
eigenvalue's lambda i can
be written as b to the
power of some set of yi.
So we just generalized
what we had done before,
now to this space that
includes many parameters.
So the story is now
something like this.
There is this
multi-dimensional space
with lots and lots
of parameters--
t, u, v, blah, blah,
blah, many of them.
And somewhere in this space
of parameters, presumably
there is a fixed point, S star.
Now in the vicinity
of that S star,
I have established that there
are some particular directions
that I can obtain by
diagonalizing this.
So let's imagine that
this is one direction,
this is another direction,
this is a third direction.
And that if I start
with a beta h-- well,
actually, let's do this.
That is, if I start with an S
that is S star plus whatever
is a projection of
my components are
along these different
dimensions, so let's call them,
let's say, ai along
these Oi hat-- just
make sure we kind of
think of them as vectors--
that under rescaling,
I will go to S
prime, which is S star plus
sum over i, ai b to the yi Oi.
That is, some of
these directions,
the component will get
stretched if yi is positive.
It will get diminished
if yi is negative.
And so now some notation
comes into play.
If yi is positive, the
corresponding direction
is called relevant.
Eigendirection is relevant.
If yi is negative, the
corresponding eigendirection
is irrelevant.
And very occasionally,
we may run into the case
where yi is 0.
And there is a terminology.
The corresponding
eigendirection is marginal.
And what that means is that I
need to resort to higher order
terms to see whether it
is attracted or repelled
by the fixed point.
So we need higher orders.
After all, so far I have only
linearized the transformation.
Now the set of irrelevant
directions to this particular S
fixed point, S star, defines
basing of attraction of S star.
So let me go back to the
picture that I have over here
and be precise and use the arrow
going away as an indication
that the corresponding
b is positive,
and I'm forced out
along this direction.
Let me choose going
in as an indicator
that the corresponding
y is negative.
And as I make b
larger and larger,
I shrink along this axis.
So in this three
dimensional representation
that I have over there, I have
one relevant direction and two
irrelevant directions.
The two irrelevant directions
will define the plane
in this three
dimensional space, which
is the basing of attraction.
So basically these
two define a surface,
and presumably any point that
is in this surface in the three
dimensional picture
under looking
at larger and larger
things will get
attracted to the fixed point.
If you are away
from the surface,
maybe you will approach
here, and then you
will be pushed out.
All right, fine.
Now let's go and look
at the following.
We have a formula,
psi of t and h.
Or quite generally,
psi under rescaling
is b times the new psi.
Or the new psi under any one
of these transformation, psi
prime, is the old psi divided
by the old correlation
length divided by a factor of b.
So if I look at
the fixed point--
so if I ask what is psi
at the fixed point--
then under the transformation,
I have the same parameters.
So psi at the fixed
point should be
the psi of the fixed
point divided by b.
There are only two
solutions to this.
Either psi of S star is 0 or
psi of S star is infinite.
Now we introduce physics.
Psi being 0 means
that I have units
that are completely
uncorrelated to each other.
Each one of them does
whatever it wants.
So this describes
essentially, let's say,
a system of infinite
temperature.
Every degree of freedom
does whatever it wants.
Well, I should say this
corresponds to disordered
or ordered phases.
Because after all,
we said that when
we go to the
ordered states also,
there is an overall
magnetization,
but fluctuations around
the overall magnetization
have only a finite
correlation length.
And as you go further and
further into the ordered phase,
that correlation
length shrinks to 0.
So there is a similarity
between what goes on
at very high
temperature and what
goes on at very
low temperature as
far as the correlation of
fluctuations is concerned.
There is, of course,
a long range order
in one case that is
absent in the other.
But the correlation
of fluctuations
in both of those cases
basically becomes
finite, and under rescaling,
goes all the way to 0.
And clearly this is
the interesting case,
where it corresponds
to critical point.
So we've established that,
once we found this fixed point,
that those set of parameters
are what can give us the scale
invariant behavioral
that we want.
Now this list is
hundreds of parameters.
So this point corresponds
to a very special point
in this hundreds
of parameter space.
So let's say there is one
point somewhere there which
is the fixed point.
And then you take
your magnet and you
change your critical
temperature,
are we going to hit that point?
The answer is, no.
Generically, you are not
going to hit that point.
But that's no problem.
Why?
Because if this
basing of attraction.
Because for any point on basing
of attraction, I do rescaling,
and I find that psi
prime is psi over b.
It becomes smaller.
So you generically
tend to become smaller.
But ultimately, you
end up at this point.
And this point, the
correlation length is infinite.
So any point on this basing
of attraction, in fact,
has infinite correlation length.
So every point on the basis
of psi prime equals to psi,
and hence psi has
to be infinite.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Question.
Why should there be
only one fixed point?
PROFESSOR: There is no reason.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So this is just an example?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So locally, let's say that
we found such a fixed point.
Maybe globally, there
is hundreds of them.
I don't know.
So that will always be
a question in our minds.
So if I just write down for
you the most general set
of transformations, who
knows what's happening?
Ultimately, we have to
be guided by physics.
We have to say that, if in the
space of all parametrization,
there are some that have
no physical correspondence,
we throw them out,
we seek things
that can be matched to
our physical system.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If there are
multiple fixed points,
do the planes of the
basing of attraction
have to be parallel
to each other?
PROFESSOR: They may have
to have some conditions
on non-intersecting or whatever.
These are only linear in the
vicinity of the fixed point.
So in principle, they could
be highly curved surfaces
with all kinds of structures
and things that I don't know.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there any reason
why you might or might not
have attracting point
that is actually
a more complicated
structure, like say,
a limit cycle or
even a [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So again, we are governed
ultimately by physics.
When I write these
equations, they
are as general as equations as
the people in dynamical systems
use that also includes
cycles, chaotic attractors,
all kinds of strange things.
And we have to hope that
when we apply this procedure
to an appropriate
physical system,
the kind of
equations that we get
are such that their behavior
is indicative of the physics.
So there is one case I know
where people sort of found
chaotic renormalization
group trajectories
for some kind of a
[INAUDIBLE] system.
But always, again, this is
a very general procedure.
We have to limit
mathematics, ultimately,
by what the physical process is.
So it's good that you know
that these equations can
do all kinds of strange things.
But then we take a
particular physical system,
we have to beat on them
until they behave properly.
So let's imagine that we have
a situation, such as this,
where we have three parameters.
Two of them are irrelevant.
One of them is relevant.
Then presumably, I
take my physical system
at some temperature
and it would correspond
to being on some point
in this phase diagram.
Some color that we don't have.
Let's say over here.
And I change the temperature.
And I will take
some trajectory--
in this case, three
dimensional space.
And this is a line in this
three dimensional space.
And experimentally, I've
been told that if I take,
let's say, my piece of iron
and I change temperature,
at some point I go
through a point that
has infinite correlations.
So I have to conclude that
my trajectory for iron
will intersect with
surface at some point.
And I'll say, OK, I take nickel.
Nickel would be something else.
And I change
temperature of nickel,
and I will be doing something
completely different.
But that experimentalist
also has a point
where you have
ferromagnetic transition,
so it must hit this surface.
Then you do cobalt, where
some other trajectory
comes and hits off the surface.
Now what we now
know is that when
we rescale the system
sufficiently, all of them
ultimately are described
at the point where
they have infinite
correlation length by what
is going on over here.
So if I take iron,
nickel, cobalt, clearly
at the level of
atoms and molecules,
they are very different
from each other.
And the difference between
ironness, nickelness,
cobaltness is really in all of
these irrelevant parameters.
And as I go and look at
larger and larger scale,
they all diminish and go away.
And at large scale,
I see the same thing,
where all of the individual
details has been washed out.
So this is able to capture
the idea of universality.
But there is a very
important caveat
to this, which is that
the experimental system,
whether you take iron or
cobalt or some mixture
of these different elements,
you change one parameter
temperature, and you always see
a transition from, let's say,
paramagnetic to
ferromagnetic behavior.
Now if I have, say, a line
here in three dimensional space
and I draw another
line that corresponds
to change in temperature,
I will not intersect it.
I have to do something very
special to intersect that line.
So in order that genetically I
have a phase transition-- which
is what my experimentalist
friends tell me--
I know that I can only have
one relevant direction,
because the dimensionality
of the basing of attraction
is the dimensionality of
the space minus however
many relevant directions I have.
And I've been told
by experimentalists
that they exchange
one parameters,
and generically they
hit the surface.
So that's part of the story.
I better find a theory that,
at the end of the day, when
I do all of this, I
find a fixed point that
not only is well-behaved
and is not a limit cycle,
but also a fixed point
that has one and only one
relevant direction, if
that's the physical system
that I'm describing.
Now of course, maybe that
was for the superfluid, where
they could only
change temperature,
and you have a situation where
the magnet comes into play
and they say, oh, actually we
also have the magnetic field.
And we really have to go
to the space of zero field.
And then if I expand
my space of parameters
here to include terms
that break the symmetry,
in that generalized
space, I should only
have two relevant directions.
So it is kind of strange story,
that all we are doing here
is mathematics.
But at the end of
the day, we have
to get the mathematics to have
very specific properties that
are dictated by very rough
things about experiments.
So this was kind of
conceptually rich.
So I'll let you digest
that for a while.
And next lecture, we will start
actually doing this procedure
and finding these kinds
of [INAUDIBLE] relations.